first joining us now with reaction
author of the upcoming book
liberal privilege donald trump jr uh
congrats on your first number one
bestseller
you know i'm watching this thank you
sean
donald trump jr 1800 questions versus 34
1803 if i'm going to be exact based on
my count i might be a little off in the
mob boy they'd jump all over me if i
didn't have the exact number
and i didn't include cardi b's
hard-hitting interview
he doesn't talk they hide him his now
is the enti your dad is running against
a ghost
a hundred percent sean and that's the
reason i wrote the book liberal
privilege because
that is the perfect example you can have
a candidate
that wants to replace the president of
the united states
he refuses to speak to anyone in the
press he's incapable of getting through
a press conference
when he speaks to a group of 10 people
he needs a teleprompter and he still
screws that up i mean
it's mind-boggling and by the way no one
in the press says anything they're oh
this is perfectly normal this is
you know joe biden i mean when you have
clear cognitive decline like this
they run him because the media can try
to sell to middle america that this guy
is somehow
a moderate but you're not a moderate if
you're appointing beto o'rourke as your
guns are
you're not a moderate if you're
appointing kamala harris as your vp
who has the most liberal record in the
senate you're not a moderate
if you put the uh bernie sanders joint
unity platform
on your website because it's the
communist manifesto of the new age sean
there's nothing moderate about biden but
the media is going to give him
billions billions worth of free coverage
hiding his obvious flaws hiding the
graft of his family
hiding the 50 years of bad decisions
that he's made in washington dc as a
swamp creature for half a century that's
not me saying it
that's robert gates obama's own
secretary of defense
who literally said joe biden has been on
the wrong side of every decision
of his entire political career that's
really saying something
that's impressive a monkey guessing at
random could have performed better than
joe biden
in terms of major decisions for america
and i haven't even started talking about
the way he built up china over that same
50 years
or iran you know sometimes he confuses
the day of the week is the office he's
running for
seems to forget that we're actually
endowed by not the thing joe you know
the thing but
god the creator of everything um you
know where was he with coronavirus ten
days after the first known case in
america he was calling
your father's travel ban and subsequent
travel bans and
the first quarantine in 60 years and
then the largest medical mobilization in
history
uh hysterical xenophobic and
and fear-mongering and where's he been
look at this guy beaten in portland i'll
re-rack it for our audience it's hard to
watch we have more coming up
this guy beaten nearly to death we don't
even know if he'll survive based on
reports we've made calls all day
um where's joe where's their solution
for that sean is to defund the police
uh reallocate it to social workers i
mean they're sitting by as blm is
destroying democrat-run cities
these are cities that have been
controlled by democrats in many cases
and in some cases for up to a century
and somehow it's magically donald
trump's fault i mean this is the
quintessential example of liberal
privilege this stuff shouldn't be
happening it cannot be going on in
america and guess what
it's not just happening in these big
cities it's only a matter of time
till the democrats who are literally
siding with criminals and offenders
over law-abiding tax-paying citizens
till this comes into your backyard sean
it's inevitable they're incapable of
pushing back
against the bad guys that's their base i
i i i cannot believe he's allowed to
stay silent
look we've known that the media they
have smeared slandered besmirch they
libel they
they're involved in conspiracy theories
and hoaxes and they have
from day one and men are after not only
your dad but as much collateral damage
as they can take
and that would be you too they ruined
carter page's life for four years and
also general flynn's life and guys like
let's see oh paul manafort
and the covington catholic kids yeah and
i'm wondering and this week is going to
be no one they won't destroy to get
their way sean
there's no one they won't destroy to get
their way look at what they did to nick
sandman
who's a 16 year old kid his crime being
a male
conservative from the south who supports
trump and happens to be a christian
i mean that's a cancelable offense today
in terms of the eyes of the democrats
it's no longer okay to simply be
apolitical you must be woke
problem with woke is the goal post move
if you're awoke today by tomorrow you're
no longer woke you're then part of the
problem
they don't know what's going on they're
run by lunatics and the reality is
the farthest left the most lunatic of
the lunatics
those are the people who are the thought
leaders of the democrat party those are
the people who are going to be pulling
you know joe biden's purse strings he's
the guy that's just the puppet
he's been a puppet for a long time but
if you don't think that he is
if you think he's the same guy all you
need to do is get on youtube
and watch a video of him in the senate
floor say 15 years ago
look at that and look at the guy today
and tell me they're the same people
the only difference is they can try to
sell to
america that joe biden is somehow a
moderate he's not
it's a lie you need to educate
yourselves before you go vote
because the media is in this game
they've given up their
the object of pretense they don't even
pretend anymore to be
objective they are liberal activists
and that's it all right donald trump jr
by the way
may not be a good week for you and your
family to watch just saying
um but uh it's only so much you know i
have to
sean it's like it's comic relief it's
comic relief at this point
it's comical but i gotta be honest you
as the american taxpayer
if their stated policies donald trump jr
ever implemented it's over
you can't recover from this madness of
socialism
you yeah you the american taxpayer have
the privilege of spending four trillion
dollars to give
health care to illegals now you don't
get that for your own family but you can
pay for theirs
education housing for criminals coming
out of president you can pay for that
but you don't get to get it for yourself
and for your kids
that is the state of the democrat party
and how's that obamacare working out
donald trump jr thank you good luck with
your new book by the way